it's hard to take a picture of a moving
target just ask any parents scientists
have the same problem with plant roots
under the microscope but now one team
has come up with a unique technique that
lets microscope to automatically track
moving objects which they use to follow
the growing roots of these tiny planes
by using lasers and glowing proteins to
piece together images in three
dimensions they even created 3d videos
of how the cells in root tips grow and
split over the course of days the team
created a special lighting system to
keep the plants healthy and turn their
microscope on its side so the plants
could grow upright a rotating plate
allowed them to study how gravity
changes root growth which could one day
help scientists understand the best ways
to grow plants in space but the
invention isn't restricted to roots the
team also used this technique with a
different microscope to watch how cells
move around in zebrafish embryos and
since they release their program for
free other scientists can use it to
capture stunning new perspectives of
just about anything that moves
you
[Music]